Daniel Jeremiah great contributor to
this program and the NFL Network he's a
former scout for the Ravens Browns and
Eagles and you can see him tonight
covering the draft ESPN NFL Network and
ABC that starts tonight at 8:00 Eastern
what is the craziest draft rumor you
have heard so far Daniel oh well I'd
heard this about a week ago it actually
ended up being true because Glazer came
out and reported it but was that Atlanta
was trying like crazy to get up to
number two to get chase young which
would have been so far to travel I just
couldn't conceive like what you would
have to give up to go all the way up
there you're talking about several
first-round picks and would have been a
heck of a move there obviously they can
make any sense for the Redskins to go
back to 16 but that one was I admire
dimitrov hey why not swing for the
fences yes they know if you don't ask
well I keep asking why isn't anybody
trying to go after that you know and
maybe that second pick overall is is so
valuable and it's gonna cost you so much
draft Capital that it's not worth going
up but if I said to you I can guarantee
chase Young is a Pro Bowl defensive
lineman edge rusher for ten years or I
guarantee that one of the quarterbacks
other than Jill burrow will be a Pro
Bowl quarterback three of those ten
years who you takin that's a tough one
day and I would probably I would
actually still take the defensive end oh
I would too I mean I mean I ten years of
elite production at the second most
important position on the field yeah but
it feels like we're we're willing to
roll the dice on tour with everything if
I had another player at another position
who I said he's had surgery on his
ankles he's had hip hip surgery and
maybe he broke his hand but hey are you
willing to invest a top-five draft pick
you wouldn't do that with anybody but a
quarterback why well I just think it
speaks to what you what everybody views
is the importance of that position and
the lottery ticket it is if you can be
that the team to keep this kid healthy
so I mean that to me is is all it is it
just comes down to the position that you
play and when you you look at the teams
that are historically picking up here
for the most part they don't have the
guy at that position so a lot of these
teams are picking up here multiple years
you know over a period of time and
they're willing to take that risk just
to try and get themselves out of this
this group and I wonder if the draft is
now starting at number three now with
the lions are the Lions gonna be able to
get somebody who wants to come up there
and and if so what are they what are
they looking to get at the number three
pick overall if you can't get chase
young and can't come jobber Oh what what
are you planning on getting at three
that makes it worthwhile well the good
news for the Lions is they could use
help in a lot of different areas Dan so
you get you get their brown and Jeffery
Okuda seems to be what the choice comes
down to so I've had them with the CUDA
and I think they're thinking as men they
would love to trade back to five or six
because they're going to get in both
those guys would probably still be there
they'll have their choice plus get a
little sugar so I would think they're
highly motivated to get out the question
is you know one of the Dolphins are the
Chargers going to do about moving up
I've got the sense for a while but I did
not think that charges were going to
move up they were content to just sit
and wait and see what what to hand
they're dealt there they were
comfortable with a couple different
options so then it comes down to the
Dolphins and and I'd argue look if
you're the Dolphins and you love one of
these quarterbacks what I should use
love I got to stop doing that with that
with quarterbacks if that confuses
everybody this year if they if they have
a passion about either to or Herbert and
you have as much draft capital as
they've amassed for this year next year
I don't know why you wouldn't just
guarantee that you get and even if you
you think there's a slim chance the
Chargers could leapfrog it don't you
just get to three it won't cost you that
much just to make sure that you get the
guy that you really really like give me
the team that's under the most pressure
tonight or the entire draft that's a
good one you know I think that I'll say
the Dolphins I mean when you have three
first-round picks and this is the this
is a rumor that I don't get maybe you
can explain this one to me so the
Dolphins trade an all-pro offensive
tackle and then they trade who's going
to be an all-pro or who already is
all pro-free safety so that they trade
these really talented position players
so that they can get all these draft
picks so they can trade these draft
picks to go up and get another offensive
tackle they hope is going to be close to
as good as the guy that they traded away
that makes absolutely no sense to me
well it feels like these offensive
tackles there's gonna be a run on
offensive tackles there's gonna be a run
on wide receivers I don't think they'll
be necessarily a run on quarterbacks
because it'll be Burrell for sure and
then maybe it's either two or herbert
and jordan love a little bit later on
but it feels like there's gonna be some
pockets in this draft that are gonna be
a little slow not too exciting there and
you're right I don't understand the
Dolphins philosophy and what they want
to do you know but Tunsil was gonna cost
you an awful lot of money and they
didn't want to keep him but as far as
you want to trade up to get an offensive
tackle instead of just there's enough
offensive tackles that could fall into
your lap that you don't waste any of
these other draft picks here that that's
the only thing on it is there a big
separation between these offensive
tackles I look I think there's I think
there's three that eyes that I really
really like and hurt on but some teams
are a little bit higher on him than I am
but he's going to be a starting tackle
now I went to Appalachian State then so
I'm not great at math but if you have
the 5th pick and we know Joe Broz going
number one and we agree there are four
really good offensive tackles in this
draft yeah
why are you trading up to get one and
unless you say he's the next Anthony
Munoz then and we've seen you know and
we were talking about this Daniel there
have been a lot of offensive tackles
taken who have been bust recently and
taken hi because I think it's hard to
handicap how offensive tackle in college
is gonna be able to play the position
which you're playing a different
position really in the way NFL blocking
and the way College is it's hard to go
that guy is gonna be great in the NFL
now we've had some guys really good it's
hard to find great offensive linemen or
at least that you go I'm gonna spend a
high draft pick on these guys you could
have an Eric Fisher here or you could
get you know mature you
Greg Robinson was really good it feels
like you can get a guard or a center and
feel more confident than you can a
tackle why is that well I think when you
look at the way the college games played
with so many tunnel screens and bubble
screens and spread you out get the ball
out it kind of eliminates these guys
having to really really pass protect for
a extended period of time which is what
you're asked to do at the NFL level now
two things I would say number one is the
NFL is starting to incorporate more
concepts like that to make that a little
bit easier for these kids and the other
thing I would say is I think there's a
there's I think we're quick to give up
on a lot of these guys like DJ Humphries
is a great example he's not a great
player Dan but the Falcons just resigned
him and gave him a decent chunk of money
because the DJ Humphries they saw in
year three and year four was much better
than the one they saw early on I think
there's just a there's a big adjustment
period for most of these guys that
tackled and when you're when you're
talking about interior guys you know
they get to play with neighbors you know
the tackle you only get one neighbors
when you play inside talking to Daniel
Jeremiah the NFL Network analyst here if
I told you you could find out what one
team is going to do tonight which team
would that be that you wanted to know Oh
easily it would be the Chargers because
because I work for him
and be the heir all my you know family
and friends that grew up you know as
fans of this team keep saying you work
for the team where they take him like I
don't know I talked to Telesca three
times a week you'd tell me anything
I don't know where they're taken who do
you want them to take well to me I just
look at them and look at and I know
we've talked about the risk with tua but
going into this kind of new era new
building
I just think him his his personality
putting him in with this group it would
be a big shot in the arm to everybody
and then they've got to go about trying
to get the offensive line fixed to
protect him but I think - oh with with
you know with Keenan Allen and Mike
Williams and Hunter Henry and Austin
heckler he's a point guard he's a
distributor and they have a nice
collection of guys he could distribute
the ball to I have doubts on unto ax not
just the medical doubts I mean that
alone I I wouldn't take him but
I understand if the dolphins do it and
they want to splash if the Chargers do
and they want to splash like I get it I
really like the kid but Chris Sims was
killing to it last night I mean he said
look I I like the kid I'm just telling
you he's not a top-ten Talent we've been
force-fed to him you know if Justin
Herbert played at Alabama would we look
at Justin Herbert differently what if
tua was at Utah State and Jordan Love
was a Taliban like is we look at you in
the system with the coach with the
results you're playing in big games
national title game like all of those
things but are we over inflating
somebody without really knowing that
we're doing that well I mean I could I
could take everything that you just said
and I could I could go back to the Year
deshaun Watson came out and I could put
it an exact same spot you know there was
it the same thing about him he's playing
look at all these NFL wide receivers
he's playing with you know he's in all
these prime time games on big stages
there's a lot of guys you can't penalize
them for who they brew they clave with I
can just tell you the difference to me
between Herbert and Toa is I think that
the 2a plays with much more urgency he's
much more decisive he's much more
aggressive now and that's not something
that changes whether you put on a
different helmet or not so that to me
would be the difference between those
two guys now Justin Herbert's bigger
stronger more athletic I get all of that
he did not play with nearly the camp the
talent that to it did I told somebody
other day I think to a played with the
best receiving corps we've seen in
college football since the Hurricanes in
the early 2000s when they had Andre
Johnson and Reggie Wayne and all those
guys I mean it was unbelievable but that
doesn't change the fact that when I
watch him I see somebody that's very
twitched up very urgent and plays
aggressive which would things I like
yeah but he plays too aggressive and he
needs to understand to take a loss throw
it away
you know Robert Griffin got into trouble
in the pros you try to take on these
guys extend to play and that Nick Saban
was on yesterday and he talked about to
is always trying to make the play make
the big play that you can't do that in
the pros because he's not fast not agree
with that
and somebody I was actually talking to
Pollock about this last night on the
phone and you know we were talking about
his inability to protect himself and I
said you know what he's not nearly the
athlete that you know Cuyler Marie or
Russell Wilson are but he needs to watch
a lot of their tape just to see how they
protect themselves it's great exactly
you're giving up giving up three or five
yards is not a big deal at the grand
scheme of things here man get down
protect yourself there's ways even when
you throw the football and you're
getting heat to be able to fall away
from the hit
I mean people used to make fun of Eli
Manning but last I checked you live
Manning played a lot of games without
missing any for the way he threw the
ball when he got under pressure it's
like I when people talk about pitching
and throwing I said if you weren't learn
to pitch watch Greg Maddux you want to
learn to throw there's a lot of guys who
can throw you want to learn to play the
quarterbacking position I you know I'd
have him watch Russell Wilson because I
think he's more like Russell Wilson than
he is drew Brees
I mean rut you must extend to play like
I you know I mean drew brees is a pocket
quarterback he doesn't get out of the
pocket he doesn't extend you know if you
if you're watching to it he's extending
he's trying runs he needs to watch
Russell Wilson and understand how to
protect yourself because that would be
the guide say watch him and your similar
size and you can see the success that
he's had yeah I mean I agree with you
that's kind of was the way I feel it's
just you've got to figure out a way to
keep yourself on the field I think when
he stays on the field I think he's
pretty darn good but that's the matter
if you can't get out there so yeah
that's the concern I mean that's you
look you're holding your breath when you
take him and you're hoping that you get
that you get that kid on the field but
there's risk
no doubt about it I don't disagree with
that Daniel goes back to the fear of
taking him and the fear of not taking
him and when's the last time that we had
a draft pick where we said that at that
position the fear of taking him in the
fear of not taking him
what's greater well I mean that's that's
I would say Johnny Manziel was that
question right this is a totally
different kid and the makeups totally
different but it was the way Manziel
played stylistically was something we
hadn't really seen and it was a question
of whether or not that would you know
that would translate but I think that
one was there's teams that were like man
I
I don't know I don't think I can take it
but man I hope he doesn't go in our
division because they thought he had a
chance to be really good yeah but this
is this is it's similar but yet
different yeah I I thought Johnny would
be if Jacksonville took him that he
would be a boost for that franchise that
it gave them personality I didn't
realize what his personality truly was
and that he he just wasn't committed to
playing playing this sport but yeah - I
do love I just I I get nervous about
that you know it's not a big kid
I mean Herbert if you said you know he's
got injuries mice still a six six kid
and he runs well he's a better athlete
than - it is he might not be a better
quarterback Jordan love might be a
better athlete but I you know there's a
mystery with him we love the mysteries
though when you think about it Daniel
it's like joy the love is intriguing
because we don't know much about him no
doubt no doubt and to me it's almost you
know we're trying that we're trying to
we're trying to judge whether or not we
have a good marriage without knowing who
the partner is so you know when we find
out it's an arranged marriage here
Daniel that's what we're doing arranged
marriage but I mean it's like it goes
back to Patrick mahomes and Andy Reid
like you can't find a better marriage
than that for him you know if if you
know Jordan love ended up with you know
Sean Payton or you know one of these top
offensive minds that had a chance to sit
and learn and develop what if he's with
Frank Reich with the Colson can sit
behind rivers for a year or two years
like that's unbelievable he's got a
great shot to be successful you know he
goes to the Miami Dolphins and they
start him next year behind that
offensive line it's not going to go well
why did everybody most people miss on
the homes well I can just talk about my
missing on him was because when you
watched him you saw unbelievable talent
but you saw him in an offense which was
a bunch of screens and scrambles that's
basically what they were doing at Texas
Tech and then it was so freewheeling and
so different from anything he was going
to be asked to do it the next level that
was difficult and then the other thing I
would say is I got a chance to visit
with him the week of the draft for the
first time
he came into our studio at NFL Network
and I asked him about specific plays
like TCU Patrick third down you're down
in the red zone fourth quarter kind of
like what you've heard Sean McVeigh do
when people ask him about specific plays
and he would tell me the play call the
read what happened on the play what what
that led them to do later on in the game
like his recall and his intelligence was
off the charts and I think the teams
that got a chance to visit with him said
okay this kid's got all this natural
talent I know we need to work on the
footwork I know there's a lot of things
to need to happen fall forward but this
kid is incredibly bright and he loves
football so when you put that kind of
stood together
that was the magic but if you could have
you could work him out physically work
somebody out or you could just interview
him like what would be more valuable you
can only pick one but you could actually
work him out or you could do what you
just did by saying hey give me the TC
you play the call you know everything
you saw in the play like what's going to
tell you more I can watch the tape and
figure out the other stuff to me it's
more valuable to to sit down and visit
with the kid you know I think that's I
think that was the that was what made
that kid so unbelievable is he gets I
mean we talked about his arm we talked
about his athleticism that dude is smart
man I said this to the Dan and so there
be Monday's where I'd come in or there
be Sundays or Saturday's where I'd be
texting them and I just say turn on
Texas too I give him the channel and
they knew that I was watching Texas too
because I said I don't know if he can
play in the NFL but damn is he fun and
it looked like he was drawing up plays
in the dirt and just saying you go over
here and you go over here he'd give me
about three seconds so I'll be able to
make something happen here I didn't know
it would translate anywhere near what it
is do Shawn Watson I thought was his
star I was shocked that he was falling
mahomes I just saw maybe the embryonic
stages of somebody who was trying to be
Brett Favre and he may turn out to be
better yeah he is unbelievable if you
could get a mulligan on one
draft grade I would I would submit my
card for that one have fun tonight and
I'll try not to text you too much okay
Oh Dan I mean if we have if we have
breaks in the Wi-Fi or something goes
area I need some text all right I'll be
your audience I'll try to pop you up a
little bit there have fun though it's
always great to talk to you Daniel I
appreciate you that's Daniel Jeremiah
he'll be working the draft for the NFL
Network